Burg Hohenzollern!
Die Burg Hohenzollern ist
ein beliebtes Fotomotiv –
nicht nur für Touristen, sondern
auch für Einheimische
wie diese Fußballmannschaft aus
dem nahe gelegenen Steinhofen.
Die Burg Hohenzollern, des [das] is’
für uns ’n Stück Heimat.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass hier jedes
Jahr etwa ’ne halbe Million Menschen
hier als Besucher herkommen
– und wir haben sie vor der Haustür.
Die Burg aus dem 19. Jahrhundert
war schon Kulisse für Hollywoodfilme.
Wie in einem Rittermärchen thront
sie auf dem Zollerberg.
Ganz schön beeindruckend, was sich die
Hohenzollernfamilie da hat bauen lassen.
Das Besondere an dieser Burg ist,
sie ist ein nationales Kulturdenkmal,
resultierend daraus, dass sie
die dynastische Stammburg
des Geschlechts der Hohenzollern ist,
die sowohl die deutschen Könige
als auch die deutschen Kaiser,
die natürlich dann Preußen
hießen, stellten
und somit Besucher aus aller
Welt hierher anlocken.
In den Schlossräumen erfahrt ihr
mehr über den Hohenzollern-Clan.
Berühmtestes Familienmitglied: der
preußische König Friedrich der Große.
Oder der letzte deutsche Kaiser,
Wilhelm II.
Bis heute ist die Burg im
Privatbesitz der Hohenzollern.
In der Stammbaumhalle –
ganz unter der Decke –
stehen die jüngsten Familienmitglieder,
darunter Georg Friedrich Prinz von Preußen.
Das hier ist Prinz Georg
Friedrich von Preußen.
Vor fünf Jahren hat er die Fürstentochter
Sophie von Isenburg-Birstein geheiratet.
Er ist heute das Familienoberhaupt.
Für Kinder gibt es spezielle Führungen mit
Verkleidung und Rittertum zum Anfassen.
Wenn du magst, darfst du das
Kettenhemd in die Hand nehmen.
Du bist doch stark.
Das wiegt sechs Kilo.
In der Schatzkammer gibt’s
Kostbares aus dem Familienbesitz:
Berühmt ist die verbeulte
Schnupftabaksdose
von Friedrich dem Großen.
In ihr blieb eine Gewehrkugel stecken –
und rettete dem König das Leben.
Hier die mit Brillanten und
Diamanten besetzte Krone
des letzten deutschen Kaisers.
Die Burg Hohenzollern ist auch ein beliebter
Ort für Verlobungen und Hochzeiten –
wie für dieses chinesische Paar.
Wir lieben die Burg Hohenzollern.